the answer to this is yes almost  everybody is it's crazy how much fear  there is  losing in business and it comes down to  one thing after listening to this for  the last decade too many people think  all losses are the same they're  there's a big difference between getting  stunned in the Ring versus getting  knocked down in the Ring versus getting  knocked the [ __ ] out in the ring they're  different and too many people in  business lump them all together people  are fearing losses that are just small  just a little loss of money a little  loss of time a little loss of your uh  ego getting hurt and your insecurities  being exposed all these little micro  losses are not a [ __ ] thing if you're  watching this video let this sink in  most of the [ __ ] that all of you are  [ __ ] scared about are micro losses  they're not you're out of [ __ ]  business you're [ __ ] dead they're  just little lumps because we're worried  about scars and scratches and bumps and  bruises stop